If you're the one leading the discussion, of course you want to test the software,...
...your microphone, your video,...
...everything related to the videoconferencing platform before the meeting starts.
In addition to that, you should ask your participants to do the same.
And there are two ways you can do that in a very polite way.
First, you can send a simple, quick email to all of the participants,...
...asking them to test the software, their video and microphone in advance,...
...especially if this is their first time using the particular platform.
One very easy sentence you can use in your email is something like:
if you've never used this video platform before, we'll open the meeting room early,...
...so that you have time to test your microphone...
...and your video before the meeting starts.
Secondly, it's important to follow through with that...
...and make sure that you're able to open the meeting five or 10 minutes early,...
...give your participants time to get set up.
Rather than just having a blank screen while your participants join,...
...you could create a slide or an image in advance...
...and share that with your participants so that they see a note...
...that says: "We will start our meeting..." or "We will start our discussion right on time."
"Please be sure to test your microphone and your video before the meeting starts."
In addition to making sure everything technical is prepared for in advance,...
...the second thing you can do in this phase is to review the agenda...
...and share that in advance as well.
If you have others who will be contributing to the discussion...
...or that you know you will ask to share some key details,...
...let them know in advance.
Give them time to be prepared so that they can be concise and clear in the meeting.